Hello everyone and welcome to lecture 7
of CME 296.
So today is a very exciting day because
we'll be talking about how to evaluate
the quality of the output of the textto
image generation models that we've been
seeing so far. And in particular, if you
think about it, in order for you to know
what to improve, you first need to know
how good your output is. So that's why
this lecture is going to be quite
important.
But before we start, as usual, we're
going to recap what we saw last time.
So if you remember last time we focused
on the training life cycle of text to
image generation models and we first
started by focusing on the loss that we
were using for training and in
particular we looked at the time step t
that up until then we assumed to be
drawn from a uniform distribution and we
saw that it was actually not fair to
treat all time steps equally. And we saw
that there was a distribution that was
quite
nice in this case which was the logit
normal distribution which emphasized on
the middle steps which are harder to
learn compared to the earlier and the
later steps. And this is mainly because
early on you have basically no
information on which for you to base
your prediction. So you just predict the
the mean of where all the observations
are and then towards the end you have
almost denoised your whole image but in
the middle you're figuring out where to
go and how you want to take those big
decisions.
So we not only saw this but we also saw
that for a given noise level if you have
a higher resolution image then you
perceive noise is going to be less than
a lower resolution image which is the
reason why you need need to do what we
call a time step shift. And we saw this
formula which hopefully is not that
haunting right now which is something
that is derived by our uncertainty of
what the underlying pixel value is.
And then what we did was go through the
whole life cycle training life cycle of
text to image generation models. And we
started with pre-training where our goal
was to teach our model how to generate
images. So we saw curriculum learning
where the goal was to teach our model
first how to do the easy things before
doing the harder things.
And then what we did was also
look at how we can handle different
resolutions.
And we saw that given that we have a DIT
based model, it's only a matter of
having a a longer input at the end of
the day.
Then we looked at post-training
approaches aimed at getting you to
generate more beautiful images. And here
we saw two main strategies on the
supervised uh side which was continued
training focusing on acquiring more
knowledge which is more relevant to the
domain you want to use your model and
then supervised fine-tuning which is
aimed at just improving the aesthetics
of the images that you produce.
And we also saw some preference tuning
methods which were aimed at capturing
negative user signals because up until
then we only taught our model what to do
but not what to not do. So this is the
goal of techniques that are derived from
gRPO, DPO and so on.
And after that we saw how we could
personalize our text to image generation
model. And we looked at dream booth
which is one such method which aims at
relying on a rare token and training
your model on the specific object or
person that you want to capture and then
use that tuned model at inference time
to be able to leverage what you have
learned at training time.
And then finally we saw an ar a range of
distillation methods which were aimed at
shortening the number of steps that you
were needing you you were that were
needed at inference time. So we saw
progressive distillation we saw um
distribution matching distillation
and here we are. Today we're going to
focus on evaluation
which as I mentioned is going to be
about assessing how good of a quality
the output generated image is.
So as as you can maybe think
judging of the quality of an image can
be quite subjective.
So
I want us to start with a motivating
example and I would like to ask you
based on an input in input prompt that
I'm going to read which hopefully is
familiar by now whether you think that
image is a good image or not. So the
input prompt is a teddy bear reading a
book
and here is the generated image. So the
question is do you think that this
generated image is a good or a not good
or bad input output?
So who says good?
Who says bad? Okay, I think we agree
it's uh an output that is not very
pleasing to see. And the main reason
here is well the aesthetics are not
great. You look at the image,
it doesn't it doesn't look great.
Okay. So, how about this one?
Do you think that this image is a is a
good image?
Okay. Who says it's a good image?
Bad image. Yeah. So, why is it a bad
image?
Yeah. So, it's indeed not representing
the prompt. Uh I agree with you. So it's
something that we call prompt adherence
where we want the output to follow what
we have it as input. And so here
although this image is is great to look
at well it's not about a teddy bear
reading a book. Okay last one.
Is this image a good image or not?
Okay. So who says good image?
Yeah. bad image.
Okay. So, why is the bad image?
Yeah. So, you have a a very um refined
taste, which is great. Um so, let's
suppose that this image is is good
enough for us because here it's first
it's following the prompt. So it's a
teddy bear reading a book and then
second it's uh it's let's say it's more
aesthetically pleasing compared to the
other ones.
Okay. So from this small scale exercise
what I wanted to point out was that when
we look at the output of a text to image
generation model we typically look at
things
with respect to two main buckets not
exhaustive but two main buckets. The
first one is if you take this picture on
its own, does this look like a [snorts]
good picture, an aesthetically pleasing
picture?
So here uh you think about whether what
is in there is physically plausible. So
for instance, if the book that your
teddy bear is reading is on the table
and not floating,
uh if uh it's realistic, if perceptual
quality is there. And then the second
big bucket is whether the produced
output is indeed following your input.
So here it's called prompt adherence.
And what we want to see is whether the
objects, the people, the locations
are indeed present in the image.
And we want uh the image to be of a
given style. And if for instance I say
okay it's reading a book uh about the
CME 296 class. I want CME 296 to be on
the book. So all of that would be within
that bucket.
But I mentioned that these two
categories are not exhaustive. Of course
you have a bunch of other criteria that
you can think of. So I'll just name a
few. So the first one is safety. So you
want to make sure you're not depicting
things that are interpreted in a in a
unsafe way.
You want to make sure that if you
generate something based on a prompt,
you're not always generating the same
thing. So you want something that is a
bit diverse.
You don't want to memorize the things
that you have seen as input. And so here
it's
trying to have some generation
generalization capabilities for your
model.
And then you have a bunch of other
dimensions. So here for instance the
bias you don't want your model to always
output the same
kind of output which could be again
misinterpreted.
So for all these reasons, what I propose
is that this image evaluation
problem, we can think of it as
us trying to think if the image that
we're getting as output is mainly
good along these two dimensions which
are aesthetics and prompt adherence.
So let's assume that these are our two
main categories that we care about.
And with that I would like to start with
a very simple and natural way of
evaluating your output which is to
leverage humans.
So here the idea is you have your model
you have some input prompt that is
having your model generate an image and
what you're saying is
okay given this prompt given this image
how would you rate this image
and so here one possible option is to
have a scale from 1 to five where one is
very bad and five is very good. And the
idea is to figure out where your your
image falls into.
So in this case, let's assume it's very
good.
Then what you would do is in order to
measure the performance of your model
across a data set, you would take the
average of the ratings. So you would do
sum of the ratings over the number of
ratings
which you can can call average rating.
So
the good thing with this score is it is
nuanced because you have a way to
distinguish a very good image versus a
good image but not a great image and so
on.
But the main drawback there is given
that you're letting more degrees of
freedom for humans to decide on which
rating that is, it can introduce some
noise in the ratings that you're
getting.
Because humans
may think that an image is a five, but
someone else can think it's a four,
someone else can think it's a three.
So everyone has their own way of
interpreting the scale and so this can
introduce some noise in the ratings.
And also if you think about it for a lot
of problems it's actually very hard as a
person to to say if something is a four
versus a five. It's just it's just a
hard problem.
And so for that reason,
a second method of digging into this
issue is instead of having a one to5
scale to reduce this problem into a
binary problem which is much easier for
humans to handle because here you are
given an image and you just need to say
whether it's good or bad.
So here we assume that the answer is
good.
And so the score that we can think of uh
in this setting is again taking the sum
of the ratings over the number of
ratings. And here it would be the pass
rates.
So how many of your images are what is
the proportion of your images that that
is actually passing the bar.
So the good thing here is it is an
easier task for humans to work on. So
the ratings are less noisy in that
sense. But one problem is humans
although it's on a binary scale they
have a hard time
evaluating things on an absolute scale.
So it's easier for you to let's say
compare two things as opposed to saying
whether that something is passing the
bar or not because you need to have some
reference.
So for that reason I want to propose a
third methods of going about doing this
which is
trying to rate those images by comparing
them to some other images. So here it's
the pair-wise comparison setting
and the setup would be you have your
input prompt and what you do is you
generate two images
and your task is to say which one of
these images is better than the other
one.
So do you agree with me that this task
is easier than the absolute scale task?
Yeah.
So, in this case, you agree that the
left one is is a better image than the
right one. So, I'm I'm glad you said no
for the the other one because I think
this illustrates the point that on an
absolute scale, people have different
expectations. So, they may think that
the left one may not be above the bar.
But when you compare these two images,
it is just obvious that the left one is
better than the right one.
And so in that sense the ratings that
you're getting are going to be even less
noisy compared to the absolute scale
binary one.
Okay. So how about the metric?
So very naively, I think a very natural
way would be to just for a given model
count the number of wins and divide that
by the number of times it was compared
to something else.
Right? So this one is the win rate.
Do you think that's a good metric?
So here what we're doing is
for each model we're generating outputs
and we're comparing these outputs to
let's say outputs of another model. What
we're what we're saying is in order to
quantify the performance of that first
model, the model A, what we're doing is
we're counting the number of times
images produced by this model one over
the opponent and we divide that by the
number of compar comparisons. So the
question is do you think that there's a
good way of doing things? Yeah. So the
the answer is um
so for one reference okay but for many
not sure. Well I I think you have the
right intuition here. So what I want to
say here is winning against a model that
is known to be excellent is much harder
than winning against a model that is
known to be bad.
So our intuition here is
your proportion of your win proportion
should not be the only factor here. You
should also consider who you are
comparing yourself with. And it's
exactly what you mentioned. And I'm not
sure if you're tracking the performance
of uh text to image generation models,
but typically you have something like
this. you have a leaderboard
where you have models that are ranked
and one challenge with this setting is
that models they come but also they can
go. So when a model comes, let's suppose
you want to have a win rate that is
reflective of the performance of that
model, you would need to have the same
model be evaluated against all models
of that list. And you want all models of
that list
to be also evaluated against all other
models
of that list every time the list gets
updated.
So this is a lot of evaluations.
So you don't want to always have to
evaluate everyone against everyone every
time something gets updated on the list
to make things appleto.
So for that reason,
well, something that we can think of is
to adjust that win rate metric by taking
into consideration
how strong your opponent is within the
metric.
So how do we want to do that?
Well,
before we go into exactly how we do
that, I just want to illustrate the
point I mentioned. So here let's imagine
we have our model let's say model A that
we want to evaluate against other
models. Well if our model wins against a
bad model
your reaction is okay and so what you
you already know that uh it's it's
better than that very basic model. So
there's nothing to be surprised about.
But if your model if the human says your
model is winning against another model
that is much much stronger then your
reaction will be different.
So the idea is to capture that within
the metric.
So let's see how we want to do that. So
first of all let's assume that we have a
metric per model that we note R. R as in
rating.
And let's assume that our model, model
A, starts with a rating of let's say a
thousand.
And we're a newcomer. And in that
leaderboard, it just happens that
there's a model, let's suppose it's a
bad model
that has a lower rating, a worse rating,
which is 600, let's say.
So
let's have our model A be compared
against that bad model. How would we
want to update the score?
So one idea could be to compute the
score that we think would happen if
those models they perform like they did
in the past.
So let's compute the expected score. And
for that let's just use this formula
which gives us the expected score. And
so here the formula would be 1 / 1 + 10
^ of the rating of the model that you're
competing against minus your rating over
some arbitrary constant. And let's
assume that that constant is 400.
Then this quantity would be your
expected
winning chance. And so here it's 0.9. So
90% chance of winning.
So now that you have your baseline, what
you want to do is compute your actual
score. So actually compare the two
models.
So here
the outcome can be one of three things.
So you can either lose,
be tied
or win over the bad model. And the idea
is to use these two quantities. So the
expected score and the actual score to
compute
your element of surprise like how much
you went above or how much you went
below.
And here it would be delta equal to the
actual score that you obtained
minus the score that you think you would
have obtained
on average.
And here in this case
if model A wins it would be plus.1.
If it loses then it's minus.9.
And if there's a tie it's also a minus
minus.4. before.
So here by the way the numbers they just
come from this formula
um that we just plug the ratings into
that and then we compute delta.
So the good thing with this observation
is we see that if we have our model win
against the bad model. Well there is not
a lot of lot of gains which is aligned
with our intuition.
And if the model loses
then it means it's really really bad. So
there is like a big contribution
downward contribution. And even if
there's a tie, we know that if we're
tied with a very bad model, then that's
also a bad contribution for our rating.
So the fourth step would be to just
update our rating by adding K * delta.
So that would be the recipe.
And so the image that I showed you like
a few slides ago was actually this slide
where I masked the middle columns. So
this is
how the leaderboards do it in practice.
They compute the score. So you may have
heard this score. It's called the ELO
score, ELO rating.
And it allows you to track the
performance of a model by
computing the score as a function of how
strong your opponent is. And this allows
you to avoid having everyone
be evaluated against everyone every
every time there is a change in who's in
the leaderboard.
And by the way, ILO is actually the name
of the person who came up with the
method. It's not an acronym. Um, so I
think that's good to note.
But what are the problems with this
approach? Well, every time we want to
evaluate our model, if we had to always
involve humans, well, it to be a very
expensive task. So that's the first
limitation.
Also humans there's always only 24 hours
in a day. It's a slow method.
It can also be subjective. So I think
the example that we had in the very
beginning is one example of that.
Another example can be okay
try to tell me if this image is well
lit. I think there are several um
notions of something well lit. So again
it's a subjective task so answers can
differ. And of course, humans are not
perfect either. U depending on the time
of the day, you may have external
circumstances that may also influence on
the quality of your ratings. So all of
that is, I hope, a motivation for us to
look at automated metrics that would
allow us to quantify how good the
outputs are.
And we're going to start with what we
call reference free metrics. And I'm
going to tell you in a second what
reference free means.
So as I mentioned, we're in the text to
image generation case. We have a text as
input
and we have a model that produces an
image. So one thing that I want to tell
you is there are just multiple ways you
can produce an image for a same prompt
like these ones.
And
for that reason,
having a single reference
image, a single image as reference is a
little bit unfair
because you would always try to compare
against that same reference.
That is not the only way you can do
things. And so for that reasons, the
metrics that we're going to see are
called reference free as in they're not
using a single output reference image as
reference. They're not doing that.
So that's the reference free.
And so let's go back to our problem. And
so here we have an input uh which is a
text text prompt. And then we have an
image as output.
And I told you we could consider our
problem as being us trying to quantify
how good the image is with respect to
aesthetics and with respect to prompt
adherence.
Well, here let's start with aesthetics
[snorts]
and let's take our generated image which
is on the right and our real image that
is on the left. So as I mentioned it is
not fair for us to compare our generated
image with a single reference. So one
idea can be to actually take many
generated images and many real images
and instead of comparing your single
generated image to the single real
image. One idea could be to look at the
distribution of both and compare how the
two and see how the two compares.
So let's do that. Well, how would you do
it? Well, in the class we've seen that
we have methods to represent images in
what we call a latent space or some some
space. So here one idea could be to take
our let's say real images
and have them be inputs into some
encoder
such that they can be represented in
space.
So we can do that with the sets of real
images
and in parallel we can also take our
generated images and also let them
through that pre-trained encoder
so that they can also be represented in
that same space.
So the idea that we can have here is to
try to compare
how these two resulting distributions in
this space how these two compare.
So in order to characterize each
distribution you can have the mean mu
and the coariance matrix sigma that can
just tell you about how your
distribution is shaped.
And what you want to do is to compare
the two. So you want to compare where
they're located. So here you can use the
mean
and how they're shaped can use the
coariance sigma. So uh the coariance
matrix is a quantity that tells you how
spread out your distribution is and also
what are the directions of of that
spread.
So, by the way, why would you also want
to quantify the spread? Well,
you also want your generated images to
be diverse. And so, here the spread
would be around quantifying how diverse
your generated images are.
And so, as I mentioned, what we want is
to quantify the distance between these
two distributions.
And so we can come up with some formula
which I'm putting it on the slide. We're
going to go through uh each component
where the first term is around
quantifying the difference in where
these distributions are located. So
comparing the means of each distribution
and also comparing the shape of each of
these distribution. So here uh so tr is
stands for trace. So it's an operation
on a matrix
and I think maybe if it's the first time
you're seeing this formula your first
reaction maybe well
why do you have this formula like what
does it represent?
So the truth is this metric which is
called the fche inception distance is a
metric that is derived from a distance
that is called the vaserstein distance
that aims at quantifying how much effort
you would have to do
to go from one distribution to another
one.
And it just turns out
that if you assume
that the distribution of real images and
the distribution of gen generated
images, they're each gausian. If you
assume that
then it just happens that this
vaserstein distance which is something
that typically does not have a closed
form solution is something that you can
express in a closed form.
So that's where the formula comes from.
But in terms of interpreting each term,
you can think of the first term as being
the difference in terms of location and
the second one is how the shapes differ.
Cool. Uh so it's a distance. So what you
want is those distances to be as small
as possible. So the lower your FID, the
better it is. Yep. Yep. So the question
is, do you can you use VLM to do that?
So we're going to see that later in this
in this lecture. Yeah.
Yeah. So the question is can you uh can
you say a little bit about how to
interpret these terms and how this
relates to this building gausian? So
we're not going to go into that. But
the underlying idea behind this metric
is to quantify how much effort you would
have to transport
one distribution to another. And this is
you can think of it as some formula that
has this interpretation. And what I was
saying was if you assume that the shape
or that your real image distribution and
if you assume that your generated image
distribution if you assume that each of
them is gausian
then what we're saying is that the
quantity that I mentioned can actually
be computed with a rather nice formula
that is closed form. So I think this
goes into the broader theme of gausian
distributions just simplifying a lot of
things and and this is one of those
instances.
So the question is the real here is the
data yes. So you would take a set of
real images, so non-generated images,
and you would compute their
representation using the pre-trained
encoder and you would use those
representations to
represent those real images. Yeah. So
the question is, can I use it in pixel
space? So here's the thing. This metric
is there for you to compare how well
your model is doing compared to other
models out there. So you need to have
some space that is the same as what the
other ones have mentioned. And so here
this metric is called fresh inception
distance because actually the
pre-trained encoder is the inception
network.
And so what you want is if you want to
compare yourself with someone else, you
necessarily mean you necessarily need to
take the same representation to make
things comparable. Yeah. So the question
is if your diffusion model is pixel
space, is this is still applicable? Yes.
So what you would do is
you have your real images that you go
through a pre-trained model. Your diff
pixel space diffusion no problem. You do
your diffusion in pixel space and at the
end you get those generated images and
you input them into that inception model
and then you have your representation.
Yeah. Yeah.
Oh yeah. Good question. So the question
is are these condition on a particular
prompt? So it's a great question. Well,
you touch a great point which is that
you want your model to perform well on
what you care about. So for instance,
you may care about generating faces,
let's say, or generating uh some nature,
some um indoor scenes. So depending on
what your task is, you may want to
compare your generated images with
respect to a set of real images that are
representative of the thing that you
care about. So you have a number of data
sets like uh so imaget is one that's
quite um uh it's a classic one and then
you have I believe ms coco and and so on
and so you can think of the images that
you generate as being conditioned by a
set of prompts that are going to match
what is there. So it can be either
captions or class conditions. So you
have something that allows you to
compare yourself to that distribution
and typically you would use a data set
that is aligned with your task of
interest and that data set would contain
the thing that you would use as input.
Yeah, great question. Yeah,
great question. So in practice, so the
question is in practice how large is the
re the set of real images that you take?
So typically 50k
and actually speaking of that we've seen
in lecture five I'm not sure if you
remember we had um
which measured its performance on that
fid 50k uh scale. So 50k here means that
we have a set of 50,000
real images.
So here what you would do is
generate 50,000 generated images and
compare that distribution with the set
of 50,000 real images.
But I've also seen 30 30,000 typically
in the order of tens of thousand. Yeah.
So uh the question is is it fair to use
variance and mean to characterize the
whole distribution? Is that is that
roughly your Oh yeah. So the question is
is it fair to assume that the shape and
the distance is representative of
quality? So it's a great question
actually one funny thing is if you look
at social media every I would say every
week you would see a new paper coming up
with the new metric. Uh so this metric
is by far not a perfect metric. Uh and I
think the community voices that out for
sure. Um, so yeah, I agree with you. It
is not necessarily indicative of the
quality that you want to reach, but it's
a good enough proxy or at least that's
what the community thinks. Uh, and I
would say, so it's a personal take. One
of the reasons why it's been hard to
change the metric that people use is
because when you want to publish a
paper, typically you want to show that
your method is is good. So you want to
compare yourself to some previous method
and people have just been using FID. So
that's why it it's it's really hard to
change from that. But I agree with your
point which is it is not necessarily
reflective of the quality of your images
which is why in papers you would also
see a bunch of I mean cherrypicked or
not cherry picked images that are shown
in the paper just to show how how good
the model is.
Cool.
Great. So I'm looking at the time. Uh I
think I will move ahead and uh just say
that the location you can think of it as
if there's a big gap in the location you
can think of it as maybe the quality or
the style being different and when it
comes to the shape being different if
for instance the generated images are is
in a very um constrained region maybe
your model is not generating diverse
sets.
So these are the points to watch out
for. And in terms of the sample size, so
as we mentioned, uh the typical
reference is FID 50k of a given data
set. Um and of course, so we're looking
at FID, which is part of this section of
reference free metrics. And here we're
using a reference distribution. So I
know that it may sound confusing but I
just want you to know that reference
free the title of this section refers to
us not comparing one generated output
with one real image. It is more about
comparing the distribution.
And then the last thing is one of the
main complaints of people is that the
distribution
of real images and the distribution of
generated images they're typically not
gausian.
So this formula is typically not 100%
valid. So the question is is this
formula only for gausian? So the formula
is actually derived from this other
quantity that's called the vaserstein
distance. And so this formula is
specifically when you compare two
distributions that are gausian.
And so that's another limitation
and a point that you will see in papers
when they're they're like okay fid is
not that great of a metric.
Cool. So this is the aesthetics. So FID
is the metric that most people use for
better or worse to quantify how good of
a quality your generated images are. And
second, as previously mentioned, we're
going to look at prompt adherence. How
can we know or how can we quantify that
the output image that we're getting is
aligned with the input?
And so for this actually you may have in
mind
a method we saw in lecture four clip
which stands for contrastive language
image pre-training
which aimed at comparing the text and an
image by encoding each separately
through their respective encoders
and training the resulting system using
a contrastive loss that incentivizes
elements that are similar to have a
higher score and elements that are not
similar to have a lower score.
So you could very well use that model
where you would put the input text that
you use to generate the image along with
the generated image.
And there's a model out there that's
called the clip score that is actually
exactly that clip model that allows you
to get
an actual score in terms of how aligned
your text and your image are.
So that's called the clip score. And
speaking of taking into consideration
both the prompt and the image,
we can also think of doing so using a
clip-like model
not in order to predict how aligned the
two are, but maybe to align or maybe to
predict
how good the image is to the input text.
So you could very well take such a model
and train it on a data set that is
around
human preferences
and that's what people did. So this is
the p score. So what they did was they
took a clip model and they trained it on
preference data where you had image and
text and the label was the preference.
And here you can get a P score which is
a holistic score that combines both the
aesthetics and
the prompt adherence along with some
other things to tell you about the
overall
satisfaction of the human with respect
to the generated output.
So this is the last metric I wanted to
talk you about.
Now I want us to take a step back.
When we talk about evaluation,
we may think about the image generation
model,
but as we saw, it's not actually the
only model we're interested in. We've
also seen other pieces that do matter.
for instance, the VAE
which is tasked with reconstructing the
input.
And in this setting, well, your label is
much much clearer
because what you want to do, your proxy
task is to reconstruct the original
input.
And so in that sense, you do have a
reference to base yourself on.
So you could very well in this setting
want to compare what you output with
what you wanted to output.
And this is the reason why in this
section we're going to go through such
metrics
which we're calling reference based as
opposed to reference free because
reference based metrics have something
that you can use to compare your
generated image against.
So I mentioned the VAE but you have
actually other use cases as well. So
we've not really gone into details about
um
image text image to image uh tasks. So
image editing tasks. But you may also
want to compare how your uh edited uh
image is with respect to the input image
to make sure you're controlling for
things that you don't want to edit and
so on. So this is not just something
that is valid for VAE but for other use
cases as well.
Cool. So just getting a bit more uh
rigorous about our notation. So the
input is noted X. The output which is an
attempt at reconstructing the input is
called or is noted uh Xhat.
And what you want is to have a
quantified metric to compare the two
that hopefully would will align with the
quality of your reconstruction.
So the first metric that you may think
about I mean the formula looks scary but
it's just about comparing pixels
just pixelwise distance
and you may also know that uh distance
under the name MSE which stands for mean
squared error and so this metric what it
does is it takes these two images and it
just computes the distance pixel wise
distance of a given pixel in the
reference image and the pixel in your
generated image. And it does that for
all pixels.
And
one big drawback is it is very sensitive
to exactly the alignment between these
two images. And so if you have generated
a perfect reconstruction but that is
slightly shifted a few pixels let's say
to the right then your MSE will be
actually terrible.
That's one drawback. Uh the second
drawback is if we tell you about an MSE
like let's say it's 10 I don't know well
you don't know what to do with that
number because it depends how you encode
your pixels. So sometimes it is between
zero and one, sometimes it is between 0
and 255 like the scale varies
which is the reason why
you have another metric that is still
pixel wise that is called the peak
signal to noise ratio PSNR
which normalizes MSE with respect to the
maximum value that it can take.
So this allows you to at least get a
reference or put things into context.
So it not only does that, it also wraps
the thing into a logarithm.
And I just want to pause here for a
second with an analogy that to me makes
a lot of sense and I hope it will make
sense to you as well. So,
if we're in a room where there is
absolutely no light
and if I just
turn on one light bulb
to you, the difference between the
complete darkness and one light bulb is
a lot.
But if in this room we have all these
light bulbs already on and if I turn on
yet another light bulb,
the perceptual difference between having
that extra light bulb in this setting
and the one light bulb that is turned on
versus darkness is very different.
So this is what this log tries to do. So
if
you you almost don't have any errors,
it's very very small value
and you have just a little bit more
error. From your perspective, it will be
more something that you would want to
notice in terms of the variation as
opposed to if you have an image that is
quite wrong that is a little yet again a
little bit more wrong with the same
delta.
So this is what the logarithm tries to
do. Well, it's great, but it is still
subject to this pixel position. So it is
sensitive to any shifting.
And this is the reason why these are not
the only metrics that people use.
And in particular,
there is one metric that you may see in
papers
that looks at how these images are
structured. So let me tell you a little
bit about what I mean here. So here
let's imagine we take the original input
and then the generated output which is
trying to be that input.
So what we're trying to do is to see if
let's say we take a given patch that is
located in the same um that is in the
same location in both uh images. What
we're trying to do is whether the two
have the same overall structure.
And what I mean by that is do the colors
have the same intensity? Does it have
the same brightness?
The second one can be does it have the
same contrast? And so here we can think
of the variance in pixel values within
that patch.
And the third one is do pixels vary in
the same fashion in the first patch and
in the second patch.
So these are the three dimensions we
care about.
And for each of them, the first one
would be around computing the mean of
the pixels in the patch in order to
quantify the the brightness or the color
intensity of the patch. The second one,
the contrast would be around quantifying
how much these pixels vary. So you can
very well take the variance of those
pixels. And then the third one is
regarding the structure. And here you
can very well take the coariance matrix
the coariance between these two uh
patches
and what you will get when you compare
the two is a similarity quantity that
here in the luminance case takes in the
mean of the first patch and the mean of
the second patch and tries to make a
number out of them.
So, is it the first time you're seeing
this formula?
Yeah. Okay. Uh, I don't want it to looks
look for this to to be looking scary.
So,
if you're looking at the formula, what
you see is there is there are two
quantities. So, let's note them A and B
in this case. And you have something
like 2 a b over
a 2 + b square.
So you also have a constant that is just
for stability purposes just in case both
of them are are zero.
But in this case you can assume that a
and b
are greater than zero.
So what can you say about this quantity?
So
from high school you may remember that
you have this very general identity
which is as follows. So a minus b^ 2
which is a^ 2 - 2 a b + b ^ 2. Well,
here you can rewrite this
as
a 2 + b ^ 2
- a - b^ 2
over a 2 + b ^ 2.
So I'm going to
replace
in place. And so here what I'm going to
say is that this is equal to one
to say here this is equal to one
minus this quantity
and here this is positive.
So this is bounded by one
and a is positive b is positive. This
quantity is positive. This is bounded by
zero.
So this is a coefficient that is between
zero and one is what I'm trying to say.
So here if a and b are similar. So if a
is equal to b
this is equal to zero it's equal to one.
So what I'm trying to say is this metric
is a similarity metric that you may
read on the you know papers I think it's
called the dice coefficient
and the reason why it's a good metric is
because it gives you the similarity of
two quantities by considering
also the values that they're at.
So I'm going to
illustrate it with with an example. So
this quantity
so if let's say a is equal to 10 and b
is equal to 20
then let's say that quantity that I'm
going to I'm going to uh let's say d
for dice dice coefficient. So that d
will be I think equal to 0.8 8 if you
compute it.
But if a is equal to 100 and b is equal
to let's say 110
then d is going to be much closer to one
and b maybe something somewhere
around.995.
So I computed this before the lecture so
don't worry I'm not uh hallucinating
things. uh but
here what I want to say is that this
idea
of
considering the level that you're at and
considering the relative difference with
respect to where you're at which we saw
with the logarithm and with the light
bulb story is also something that is
captured here. So even though A and B
are 10 apart,
here they are less similar than here.
So all of that to say that I hope that
when you look at this formula,
it doesn't look as you know something
that came out of the blue. So in this
formula on the slide, we're using this
way of computing similarity
using the mean of the pixels which gives
you the luminance similarity.
You can do the same for contrast. So
here you use the variance and the
standard deviation.
And you also have one for the structure.
Well, this one is a little bit
different.
um you're actually using the Pearson
correlation
which gives you a quantity that is
between minus1 and one.
So let's assume you've done that for
luminance, for contrast, for structure.
And just for simplicity, let's note them
L, C, and S.
What we're doing is we're just
multiplying everything.
So if things are similar, they're equal
to one.
If things are not similar then L is
equal more equal to zero. C is tending
to zero and S the correlation is tending
to minus one.
And so this is exactly what we mentioned
and as a result you are getting this
formula which you may have seen in
textbooks. I think it looks really scary
when you just look at this formula
firsthand, but
with this way of looking at things, I
hope it will not look scary anymore.
And so you do that operation for all
patches
and the resulting metric that you obtain
is the average of those scores across
your patches
and you get a metric that is called the
SSIM. So the structural similarity
which is a score between minus1 and one
where the more the closer you're to one
the more similar the images should be
from a structural perspective.
Okay. So, but you may tell me, well,
it's on patches. What if your shift is
beyond the patch? And I will say, yeah,
you're completely right. This metric
although being less pixel dependent than
the MSE and the PSNR is still sensitive
to that pixel shift which is the reason
why there is a final metric I want to
talk to you about which we actually have
already seen in lecture I believe four
which is the LPIPS
the learned perceptual image patch
similarity
and That one is actually quite simple.
Instead of comparing your X with your X
hat in the pixel space,
what you do is
you take each quantity and you let them
through a pre-trained encoder and you
compute the representation
that this encoder has, which tells you
more about how perceptually similar they
are as opposed to exactly how aligned
they are from a pixel perspective.
And so here you have this distance
between 5 L X and 5 L Xhat. So the L
represents the layer of that pre-trained
encoder.
And you also have a coefficient W
which is actually a coefficient that was
determined such that the resulting
metric aligns with human perception. So
I believe these were tuned because uh
there was like a data set of images and
uh the idea was to tune this metric so
that it's as aligned as possible with
the human perception levels
and that metric is actually quite
commonly used and so you may see it
quite often. Uh the only problem to call
out I mean only top of mind is that it's
not super interpretable in terms of what
is going wrong. So if your uh metric is
not doing great you need to see what's
going on
and that was it. Any questions before?
Yep. So the question is for this last
one which pre-trained model is there to
use? So I believe it is VGG
among so I think there's alexnet as
well. Um the reason why we have some
preset encoders is because the
coefficients WL are dependent on the
encoder that you use.
So you can use the you know libraries
and mention which encoder you you you
want to leverage but typically it's
either VG or Alexand.
So the question is what does the formula
mean? So within the distance what you
have is two terms. One is the difference
between the feature map of X and feature
map of Xhat
and you multiply that element wise with
the coefficient WL.
Does that make sense? Perfect. Yep.
So uh the question is this was for two
images. How do you apply to the batch?
So just as a reminder,
we're looking at cases where we care
about how good of a job we did about
reconstructing an input.
So what you care about is how far off
you are. And so this metric tells you
how far off you are in trying to
reconstruct an input. And so if you want
to aggregate, you can use the
traditional aggregations like a mean uh
and so on.
Cool.
Great. With that, I'll give it to
Shervin. Thank you, Ain. So, exactly as
we saw, all of these metrics, they're
very mathematical, and what we want is
have a way to interpret them from an
intuition standpoint.
So
we saw that all these metrics they were
operating at different levels and there
are many of them. So what I'm going to
do is invite you to do a little detour
and visit a class of models that we call
multimodel LLM because they have the
nice property of being able to convert
text and image data into text. But
before we do that, let's do a little
summary of the kinds of models we've
seen so far in the class. So we saw the
transformer at some point that we know
transforms bits of text to text. So this
is not something that we can use out of
the box. We saw dit where based on
latent noise and potentially a condition
you could generate an image. So here
it's a generation of images. This is
also a kind of model that we can we
cannot reuse as is. And same for MMDIT
where the input was guided by
potentially text not just a condition.
And here we're in this sibling problem
of dealing with both modalities except
that we want image and text at the input
in order to find a way to judge them and
get text as output.
So
this is typically the setup that we're
interested in. So we have a model, we
have um like the picture, let's say here
a teddy bear and we ask a question that
would guide the evaluation. So let's say
how cute is this teddy bear? And you
would want such an evaluation model to
give you the answer.
So before starting all of this, I just
want to make the problem a bit more
concrete. what do we have at hand? So
when we talk about images and when we
talk about text, what we can do is
convert them to tokens.
And at the end of the day, tokens,
they're just embeddings. So we're facing
the problem of trying to find an
architecture that can accept these
embeddings and turn them into
interpretable text.
So one thing that comes to mind so if
you recall the architecture of the
transformer let's say you have a text
based text based model one natural
choice could be to leverage that cross
attention layer that could enable you to
make text tokens attend to anything you
want and that anything you want the keys
and values of cross attention
could very well be images.
So this is one possible direction where
you use uh text tokens as input of your
um of your decoder and then you keep
this cross attention mechanism in order
to make it interact with encoded images.
So
this is something that people have done
uh because it's a very natural thing to
do and it's also quite efficient
computationally because you leverage a
fixed context length only composed of
text and then you make it interact with
images. So there is one example here
that we can site of a model that did so
flamingo by Google where images are
given as keys and values and you have
some placeholder token that gates when
it's fine to attend to these images. So
this is one possibility.
But one caveat of this mindset is that
you cannot directly leverage the latest
advances in large language models
because as you know these are decoder
only models and they have gotten rid of
that cross attentional cross attention
altogether. So you cannot use all these
latest models that have been tuned and
work great out of the out of the box.
You need to re-engineer that cross
attention layer in there. So this is why
you see a second branch of dealing with
multimodel input which is to directly
feed these image and text tokens as
input.
And one example
um of such model is a lava. So here you
use uh an encoder to to find the right
embedding for this uh tokens for for
image patches like a VAT model and then
you you give it to to that decoder only
structure.
Okay, great. And these days exactly for
the reason that I mentioned
like quality but also the fact of
reusing wins this ladder technique is
what people use in practice. So all the
latest MLM that you might see are based
often times on putting both images and
text as input of the decoder, not doing
cross attention.
and
they they have some capabilities that I
that I'm mentioning here. We're not
going to go into details uh about them
but I want you to be aware of them
because we're going to actively use them
at the time we want to use these models
for judging.
So one is working uh with all kinds of
images. Yeah. So there's a question
here. Yeah. So the question is what do
you mean by reuse existing winds? So
so I think it's an engineering question.
I think you could definitely reuse
something uh already trained like have
weights frozen and and start from there.
This is one possibility. I was more
thinking about an architectural
standpoint where you have a design that
that is proven to work. this is just
another modality with a same kind of
input that you can just recycle but then
on how you actually come up with such a
model I think it's more of a engineering
problem um so I don't give a specific
opinion on it but I I I do think you
could definitely initialize weights um
and and reuse it you know in in a strict
sense of the term
okay so we want these models to be um
working across all kinds of inputs and
in particular one property that you want
your models your generative models is to
generate text as part of your images. So
let's say if you uh want to generate the
image of a sign you want the the the
text to be readable. So you would want
models that do judge these kind of
generated images to be aware of uh of
characters. So this is why I mentioned
OCR
and um and then also one other thing
which I think was mentioned here is we
do not want to have a black box that
just gives us a number. We want to have
some rational behind what grade that we
give. So this is why
leveraging reasoning abilities of such
models is going to be something that we
want to use.
Okay, great.
So now I want us to look at traditional
metrics and then find some of the key
concerns we had and see what could be
ways to mitigate them.
So one thing that we were concerned with
with traditional metrics was that you
get a number but at the end of the
number at the end of the day you don't
know what to do with it. Right? Let's
say you have a prompt that gave a given
image and you have a certain clip score.
Now what do you do with it? So this is
something that you could fix by taking
the prompt and trying to reason about
what properties in the generated image
could make it such that the image would
match the prompt.
And this is uh something that you could
do by decomposing what you care about
into atomic properties. This is what the
TIFA
uh paper does. So text to image
faithfulness
evaluation where they use fot learning
to show examples of what interesting de
compositions of what you care about in
an image might look like and they apply
it to a given prompt to generate a set
of questions. And these questions are
very simple. they're just yes or no or
things where the answer is obviously
right or wrong. So that way you
decompose the
like the the judging into dimensions
that are quite quantitative
and what you do is that you take MLM
model to assess each of these dimensions
independently. So, for example, here uh
this teddy bear reading a book. Is it a
teddy bear? So, yes. Is it cute? Yes. Is
there a book? Yes. And is the teddy bear
reading the book? Yes. As well. So, such
a metric would give you a score that
matches the fact that all of these
criteria were met.
And it's it it's quite uh interesting
because in the in the case of clip
score, even though you have an image
that semantically matches your input
prompt, you're not exactly sure what
that remaining delta is about. And with
a method that decomposes these concerns,
you could pinpoint what goes wrong.
So, so it's quite simple and um you know
you could de debug where the issue comes
from. But on the other hand, this method
of generating dimensions that you care
about per image is quite bespoke because
you're here at every prompt
uh that you input your data set, you
need to have a a a grading
rubric that is specific to that prompt.
So the fact of generating that rubric in
the first place is going to be expensive
and it might be errorprone.
And something else is that you have all
of these questions that examine multiple
sides of that prompt, but the weighing
of each of these claims might not match
the importance of what each claim uh to
your point of view. So for example here
if you uh if you don't have a book at
all then you might have one or two that
goes away and you would have maybe half
of the metric that I mean the the metric
would be about half of the max score but
it necessarily might not be what you
want. So you might want a way to
generate a rubric that is more
robust to that.
Um yeah, I'm going to take a pause for a
few seconds and see if that makes sense.
Okay, awesome. Uh so I'm going to state
another complaint. Uh so
so here we saw clip score and one great
thing about clip score is that it can
try to convey whether the semantic
meaning of a generated image was
preserved. But one thing that we observe
is that semantically encoding the
meaning of a prompt within a vector and
then doing some dot products with
respect to the embedding of the image
might not carry all the semantic
subtleties that prompt variations might
convey. So here one thing that we
observe in practice is that in the cute
bear reading a book example if you
exchange book and teddy bear from a
semantic perspective like to your
intuition it changes things quite a bit
right you would have totally another
image in mind but from a clip score
standpoint it turns out that the score
doesn't change that much so you could
explain this by the fact that you're um
that you're projecting
all of the image and all of the content
of the prompt [music] into vectors and
these are not very richly conveying all
these subtleties.
But also one other explanation could
reside in the way that uh clip is
trained because you have you are
incentivized to match images and prompts
in a way that matches those that
correspond with respect to text image
captions. But you have this concept of
inbatch negatives that we saw at the
time where we introduced clip where you
try to make the distance between images
and prompts that have nothing to do with
that image
further apart. So you
don't really have an incentive to learn
these subtleties. And these are the two
main reasons why uh clip score is not
that great.
So, but you might tell me okay Shervin
clip was generated with the embedding of
the entire sentence. Uh because as as we
remember you would encode the meaning of
a given sentence with a decoder uh and
then extract the last embedding which
contains the embedding of the whole
sentence. So one thing we can do is
have the same um
have the same property with a trick
where you input both the image and the
sentence in the same embedding and then
extract the probability of whether
both image and sentence are supposed to
match or not. So this is something that
is called VQA score where the template
is very simple. So you you always follow
this same structure where you put the
image and then you ask yourself does
this fe figure show and the content of
your prompt and then what you do is that
you look at your probability
distribution of your next token and you
look at the one that corresponds to the
token yes and you say that that
probability is going to be your score
which means that if the sentence is
semantically
similar or matching to the image, you're
going to have a high probability and
lower otherwise.
So by doing so
you can alleviate this
issue that we had seen at the clip score
level where you were comparing vectors
in a coarse fashion and now you're
directly reusing the structure of the
decoded output in order to embed both
modalities in a way that makes sense. So
yeah,
so the question can a regular LLM do it?
So very pedantically no because you have
image modality in there but let's say
the question is for MLM. Can a standard
MLM do it? So the we advocate that yes
because it is trained to
yet to understand broader concepts. So
it's a zero shot it's a zero shot task.
Uh so yeah so that's a great point. It
emphasizes one benefit of this
technique. You do not need to train
anything in a bespoke manner. You just
take an off-the-shelf MLM that does uh
that does know how to um understand
things.
Okay. Great.
So, but one drawback that you might
notice is that this technique relies on
you having access to the probability
distribution of the next token. And if
you take all the latest and best models
out there that might be closed source,
they do not disclose the probability
dist distribution of the next token. If
you are in the field of distillation,
you know it's a very sensitive topic
because you can learn a lot of things
from it. So this is not something that
you have access to and something else
that is wasteful is every time you ask
such questions you need to do a
dedicated MLM call and these are quite
expensive. So from a user standpoint,
you could say, okay, fine, I have a
provider. I will do all of them in
parallel and wait for the max of all of
them to finish to have my result, which
is not that bad often times, but it's
quite costly as it scales with the
number of decomposed dimensions.
And everything that I've mentioned here
is focusing on the prompt of your data
set. So you're inferring your conditions
and dimensions off of the prompt of the
data set.
There seems like a better way to do it.
Like you're still stuck in these ancient
worlds where you try to engineer
everything, even metrics. You try to
engineer them in order to make sense of
them afterwards. But
one shift of paradigm that seems
attractive here is instead of being
prompt ccentric be concept ccentric of
what you consider to be good and then
describe that goods in a generic way and
then leverage all of the reasoning
capabilities of these MLM models to do
that sort of reasoning of your on your
behalf and come up with the final score.
So, does everyone agree that this
strategy sounds attractive?
Okay, great.
And this brings us to um a paper that
popularized this mindset called VIE
score. visual instruction guided
explainable score where you give your
prompt, you give your generated image
and then you describe a rubric and Afin
if you remember at the beginning of the
lecture he mentioned two axes where we
broadly had an interest in. So one is
semantic consistency and the other one
is perceptual quality and this effort
formalizes how we could write rubrics
and grades for both of them. So you
would have such a rubric and then ask an
MLM about it and then since this task is
about judging you call such a model MLM
as a judge.
And the good thing about these models is
that they are interpretable and you can
ask them to output uh some reasoning
before prompting them for a given score
which is what this paper does
and
width are two
dimensions that we care about. So
semantic consistency and perceptual
quality respectively uh denoting whether
the image follows follows the prompt and
whether the image looks good. So you
could have two different generations and
you might smile at the second one
because it's not very realistic which is
why you might so it's technically still
reading the book on the right hand side
but on uh the natural aspects this is
where an MLM as a judge might come in
and and just you know keep us in check.
Okay, great. And just formalizing the
fact of asking about an MLM as a judge
opinion regarding grading a given
dimension. So typically what you would
have is that you first give your input
and then you handcraft a set of
guidelines with respect to each of the
dimensions of interest and then you ask
your MLM as a judge to output its
decision in some given format. One that
is popular is JSON because you can then
parse scores and rationals and anything
else that you care about in a structured
way by just accessing fields.
And
one question that comes to mind is how
to ensure that the rationals and the
scores actually do make sense.
So here comes the I think most
interesting part of the lecture which is
once you have a problem where you have a
judge that you want to use to grade your
images, how are you going to make them
aligned with what you as a human find
good. So this is the first stage where
you would take in um in an actual you
know in a true setting you would take
your prompts you would take your
generated images and you would typically
ask humans to grade them alongside the
rubrics of interest. So let's say you
have perceptual quality and semantic
consistency. You would first get a sense
of what is good versus bad from a human
standpoint.
And the second step would be to
handcraft rubrics that would match human
intuition. So these days handcraft is a
bit of a
um you know it's a bit of a strong word
because you wouldn't actually handcraft
this. would ask a model to
handcraft instructions that would be
such that
the resulting ratings would match human
intuition.
And once you have that then you can
further judge other prompt image pairs
with that trained judge.
So this is a three-stage way of solving
this problem. So first
just asking your intuition about what is
good then tuning the MLM the MLM's
rubrics about it and then third one
would be uh directly asking the MLM
about new images.
Okay. And um so you might have multiple
settings where you would ask for like
for advice. So you have a pointwise
setting where you have a given image, a
given prompt and you want to know if if
the if the result is good. You have the
pair-wise setting that Afin also
mentioned. And you have another one
where you have a prompt, you have a list
of images and you want the model to um
to rank them. So going one by one in
practice pointwise is great when you
want to do one-sided evaluation of your
of your images. So just to have a rough
idea but also to debug what goes well
versus doesn't go well because as you
remember you have this rational
side of the MLM as a judge output that
can guide you towards understanding loss
modes of um of your of your model. So it
can either lead to you iterating on the
image generation model or coming back to
the calibration of the judge itself
because it might not corresponds to the
intuition that you have in mind. So it's
great for doing both of them. Uh another
setting is the pair wise one which is
great when you want to compare models
with each other. So typically if you
have a new iteration of the model and
you want to know if it's fine to replace
it altogether you would use this kind of
mode. And then regarding ranking, even
though that's something that's studied
in papers, it's typically not used in
practice because um the ordering might
be too sensitive and so you have a lot
of variance and often times the ranking
of several outputs might not be
something that you want to do as a
oneshot task. So it might not have as
broad
um so applications as it as the two
other ones.
Uh so I just want to spend a few minutes
to talk about breast practices overall
when you deal with uh ML when you deal
with MLM as a judge. So here we saw with
VIE score that you could decompose what
you care about into two dimensions. But
in real life you might have use cases
where you have a task specific
rubric that that is not general but that
might be specific to what you care
about. So you would typically decompose
and isolate that as a separate metric
and make the judging be done on all
these sets of criteria including that
other one that would be designed to be
atomic and isolating what you care
about.
So another thing is that empirically
you typically want your model to output
the rational before outputting a score.
uh because in the LLM space you have all
this research around concepts
surrounding chains of thoughts and how
it improves the like performance and and
the intuition for it is that even as a
human when you want to form an opinion
on something it's always good to
enumerate facts about it. just
say out loud what you have in mind when
you do like a piece of judgment before
actually doing the judgment.
So this is a good practice.
Um something else is that with LLMs you
have this temperature parameter that you
can um that that controls how creative
and how deterministic versus stoastic
your output gets. And typically when you
use u like chatbots these are not set to
zero. So outputs are typically
nondeterministic because uh quality is
typically better when it's
nondeterministic for a range of tasks.
But for very precise tasks like um like
judgment where you're
when you are grounded on the input that
you're given and the rubrics that you're
given. This is typically
um a use case where it's fine to make it
set to zero and also because you want
determinism across your MLM as a judge
runs.
Uh something else is that you might see
position bias if you are in a pair wise
setting. So it's good to swap the
ordering of the two samples that you
want to compare.
And the last point is something that we
mentioned just before. we want to make
sure it's aligned with human judgment
before actually going ahead and um and
then trusting it blindly. So I want to
spend the last five minutes uh talking
about the main benchmarks that cover
some of the characteristics that we care
about on image generation. So
on benchmarks
I I will go through like points that
cover overall areas that we care about.
So one is let's say you have a prompt
you want to make sure that whatever is
generated contains the objects and some
highle attributes that you mention in
your prompt. So this is where um gen
eval it's it's one possible benchmark
comes to mind where you have a six tasks
of increasing difficulty that talks
about objects uh like counting of
objects colors of objects and relative
position as well as uh attribution of
colors.
So the judges here are object detection
uh models that will come in and then
detect whether the right objects or the
right colors were generated. So this is
one example. So you have a photo of a
purple backpack and a white umbrella and
you want to make sure that
both objects and colors are correctly um
attributed.
and something else that you care about
that might touch on uh something that
you mentioned. So when you deal with
dense prompts, so typically prompts that
are very detailed, you want to make sure
that all of the details are correctly
rendered. And this is why this DPGB
bench benchmark has uh a mechanism that
looks a bit like what we saw in TIFFA
where you have this big chunk of text
that you decompose into a set of atomic
yes or no questions. And the interesting
thing about this paper is that it groups
all of these claims into a graph that is
logical. So here you have a big chunk of
text and it decomposes into questions
that are centered on attributes,
relationships and uh spatial
um yeah special location.
And let's say you want to judge about a
given attribute. So here that long uh
bunch of text mentions u an empty space
where an invisible man has this and
that. So first you need the empty space
to exist and this benchmark looks at it
in a course to fine mindset. So if the
prerequisite doesn't exist then you
don't even bother looking at the other
conditions. So this is what makes this
benchmark interestingly
uh efficient
and uh conversely if if one precondition
exists then you move on to the next next
pieces of the graph.
So this is another area.
So something else that we had mentioned
regarding capabilities that we were
interested in was OCR as a capability
and on the image generation side you
might want to generate images that have
walls of text in there and you want to
know how well they are rendered. So
there is a long text bench that could be
mentioned where you have um like
scenarios where displaying text might be
seen as interesting from an image
generation perspective and the paper
uses a VLM uh like typically an OCR
judge that will try to render the text
in the generated image and it will match
to the reference text that was used as a
generation prompt and if both match then
we say that the text was correctly
generated. So it's one other interesting
application
and then the last one I will mention is
on another uh image generation mode that
is of interest typically when you want
to generate an image. So if you want to
operate on top of a given image. So here
uh like J grounded edit bench. So I put
a question mark because it's not
explicitly spelled out in the in the
paper but the like the abbreviation
meaning but the grounding part is on the
input image that is given. So you ask a
task about it for example um like
replacing some background changing
colors and so on. So you have 11 such uh
tasks and you use um like MLM as a judge
model that operates on both perceptual
quality and semantic consistency to
judge the output. So here's an example
from here's the figure from their paper
on what it looks like.
And I just want to say one last word
about all of this. Sometimes you might
be overwhelmed with all these metrics.
So we saw at the beginning of the
lecture a bunch of quantitative ones. We
saw MLM as a judge ones that are still
imperfect because they depend on how
well you tune it. So there is no
absolute way of knowing how something
performs and you might be
prone to only relying on a few sample
images as a way to have an opinion about
a given uh image uh model. Um but I want
to say that so let's do the following
thought experiment.
If you consider not the procedure of
picking the next image that is generated
by your model but the best of three
versus the least well of three then you
see the corresponding distributions are
quite different. So from a same image
generation model, you could handcraft
different distributions just by the way
you go about sampling what you want to
display to someone. So yeah, I just want
to put a caveat on when you see images
doesn't tell the whole story either.
And with that, thank you very much for
coming here despite the long weekend. I
hope you have a great one.